maybe there's a lot of things to ask
there maybe just to linger on NATO
expansion what is NATO
expansion what is the threat of NATO
expansion and why is it such a concern
for
Russia
NATO was a mortal enemy of the Soviet
Union during the Cold War it's a
military Alliance which has at its heart
the United States of America which is
the most powerful State on the
Planet it is perfectly understandable
that Russia is not going to want that
military Alliance on its doorstep here
in the United States we have as you well
know what's called the Monroe Doctrine
and that basically says no great powers
from Europe or Asia are allowed to come
into our neighborhood and form a
military alliance with anybody in this
neighborhood uh when I was young there
was this thing called told the Cuban
Missile Crisis the Soviets had the
audacity to put nuclear armed missiles
in Cuba we told them in no uncertain
terms that that was not acceptable and
that those missiles had to be removed
this is our backyard and we do not
tolerate distant great Powers coming
into our neighborhood well what's good
for the goose is good for the gander and
if we don't like great Powers coming
into our neighborhood it's hardly
surprising that the Russians did not
want NATO on their doorstep uh they made
that manifestly clear um when the Cold
War ended and they exacted a promise
from us that we would not expand NATO
and then when we started expanding NATO
they made it clear after the first
trunch in 1999 that they were profoundly
unhappy with that they made it clear in
2004 after the second trunch that they
were Prof profly unhappy with that
expansion and then in April 2008 when
NATO announced that uh Ukraine and
Georgia would become part of NATO they
made it unequivocally clear not just
Putin that that was not going to happen
they were drawing a Red Line in the Sand
and it is no accident that in August
2008 remember the Bucharest Summit is
April 2008 and August 2008 you had a war
between Georgia and Russia and that
involved at its core NATO expansion so
uh the Americans and their allies should
have understood by at least August 2008
that continuing to push to bring Ukraine
into NATO was going to lead to disaster
and I would note that there were all
sorts of people in the 1990s like George
Kennan William Perry who was Bill
Clinton's Secretary of Defense the
chairman of the Joint Chiefs of Staff
Paul Nitza and so forth and so on who
argued that NATO expansion would end up
producing a disaster which it has I
would note that uh at the famous April
2008 Bucharest Summit where NATO said
that Ukraine would be brought into the
alliance Angela Merkel and uh Nicholas
sarosi the German and French leaders
respectively
opposed that decision Angela Merkel
later said that the reason she opposed
it was because she understood that Putin
would interpret it as a declaration of
war just think about that Merkel is
telling you that she opposed NATO
expansion into Ukraine because she
understood correctly that Putin would
see it as a declaration of war what did
the United States and its friend in
friends in Europe do they continued to
push and push because we thought that we
could push NATO expansion down their
throat after 2008 the same way we did in
1999 and 2004 but we were wrong and it
all blew up in our face in
2014 and when it blew up in our face in
2014 what did we do did we back off and
say well maybe the Russians have some
legitimate security interest no that's
not the way we operate we continue to
double down and the end result is that
in 2022 you got a war and as I've argued
for a long time now we the West are
principally responsible for that not
Vladimir Putin so the expansion of NATO
is primarily responsible yeah to put it
in more general terms what we were
trying to do was turn Ukraine into a
western bulwark on Russia's border and
it really wasn't NATO expansion alone
NATO expansion was the most important
element of our strategy but the strategy
had two other dimensions one was EU
expansion and the third was the color
Revolution we were trying to force
orange revolution in Ukraine and the
basic goal there was to turn Ukraine
into a pro-western liberal
democracy and that meant that you'd have
Ukraine if it worked as a pro-western
liberal democracy that was in the EU and
that was in NATO this was our goal and
the Russians made it unequivocally clear
Ukraine was not going to become a
Western bullwark on their border and
most importantly they made it clear that
Ukraine in NATO was
unacceptable